[Musique]
salut il y a des sujets qui vous
passionnent toute une vie pour ma part
c'est le cas sur la tripty qui réunit le
temps qui passe la substance de l'échec
et la concrétisation d'une idée les deux
premiers thèmes je les ai traités dans
des livres que j'ai écrit mais je
m'étais jamais confié sur comment
transformer une idée en quelque chose de
réelle quelque chose qui existe dans la
vraie vie le truc qui n'est ici et que
vous pouvez rendre vrai dans le monde
matériel des idées on en a tous on va
découvrir aujourd'hui comment elles
apparaissent dans notre cerveau et
pourquoi dans la grande majorité des cas
ça reste qu'une idée parce que que ce
soit pour des projets perso ou des
objectifs professionnels la difficulté
qu'il y a de transformer une idée en
réalité c'est un problème que toute
l'humanité expérimente nous allons aussi
parler de tout ça avec des personnes que
vous connaissez en tout cas peut-être
les Rhino un humoriste qui est également
présent sur Youtube
Eric l'archevêque un entrepreneur qui a
créé le leader mondial de la sécurité
pour les applications de crypto et que
vous avez pu voir dans la mission qui
veut être mon associé Ludovic B il est
journaliste et créateur sur Youtube pour
la chaîne le tattoo et sa chaîne Ludovic
B et Pauline legno du podcast à succès
le gratin qu'a créé sa propre marque de
joaillerie sans rien y connaître à la
base parce que vous les connaissez parce
qu'ils ont personnellement
artistiquement professionnels mais
beaucoup moins pour les difficultés
qu'ils ont eu à persévérer et à ne pas
abandonner en cours de route la
thématique de transformer une idée en
réalité elle est beaucoup plus grande
qu'il n'y paraît c'est un sujet qui
touche au cerveau et dont les mécanismes
psychologiques n'ont pas vraiment changé
au cours des derniers siècles si vous
connaissez mon livre votre temps est
infini vous serez pas étonné d'apprendre
que j'ai creusé ce sujet depuis plus de
20 ans parce que je voulais être sûr de
pouvoir moi expérimenter tout ce qui
traversait ma tête et je pense que cette
vidéo va vous faire fondre quelques
neurones je m'appelle Fabien olicard je
suis fasciné par les mécanismes du
cerveau qui permettent de matérialiser
une simple idée sans abandonner et
aujourd'hui sort mon septième livre
votre idée va devenir une réalité qui
traite de la naissance d'une idée des
différences entre motivation et
persévérance des obstacles quand on se
lance dans un projet ou dans un objectif
des solutions que j'ai pu développer
pour moi ces 20 dernières années je vous
en parlerai à la toute fin de la vidéo
pour le moment direction notre cerveau
pour comprendre comment aller au bout
d'une simple idée
[Musique]
le point de départ d'un projet ou d'un
objectif c'est toujours une idée mais
alors ça apparaît comment une idée
comment on sait que c'est la bonne idée
à suivre parce que c'est pas vraiment
difficile d'avoir une idée même une idée
brillante mais les réaliser toutes en
même temps avec la même énergie pour
chacune c'est évidemment impossible
alors comment faire pour déterminer
celle qui a mené jusqu'au bout si je
consacrer de l'énergie à toutes les
idées que j'avais je pense que je m'en
sortirai pas et donc on est obligé de
trier mais si on a une un moment qui
s'accroche qui persiste et qui arrive
pas à sortir ou qui frappe parce que
parfois c'est des révélations moi ça
m'est déjà arrivé de me prendre une idée
dans la figure et vraiment d'être
physiquement en fait affecté par cette
idée et c'est pas tellement parce que je
pense que l'idée est bonne c'est parce
que je sais que je vais repartir vers un
projet que je ressens le début d'une
grande histoire c'est surtout ça c'est
l'idée c'est la prémisse du Grand
histoire en fait ce qu'il faut
l'envie elle souhaite tellement forte
que j'arrête pas d'y penser et que du
coup l'idée ne part pas d'une certaine
manière c'est quand elle reste un peu
indépendamment de ma volonté il faut que
je continue il faut que je creuse il
faut que tu aies tellement envie il faut
que ça soit presque mais honnêtement
viscérale que du coup oui c'est dans ces
moments-là que je sais que c'est la
bonne idée c'est quand je sais qu'en
fait il y a pas d'échappatoire quoi
c'est l'idée qui arrive et je dois me
rendre compte que c'en est une sinon le
reste du temps je dois écrire et donc
l'idée vient avec le travail d'écriture
mais j'ai pas ce truc là de génie qui
attend dans son fauteuil et que ça ça
tombe j'ai pas assez de sensation que
l'idée vient me chercher dans mon
quotidien quoi plus c'est nouveau pour
moi et loin de finalement ce que j'ai
l'habitude de faire dès que ça peut me
sortir de un peu ma zone de confort je
pense c'est ça aussi qui fait le critère
pour moi d'intérêt en tout cas tous mes
invités viennent d'univers et de
parcours différents mais comme vous
voyez leur ressenti est similaire une
nouvelle idée c'est comme une drogue
dure on y pense tout le temps en réalité
ça génère de la dopamine dans le cerveau
c'est une hormone endogène créée par
notre cerveau qui cette phase
d'excitation on n'a pas encore
conscience de l'énergie qui va falloir
déployer pour rendre tout ça concret
j'ai d'ailleurs demandé à mes invités ce
qui ressentent émotionnellement
lorsqu'ils ont une idée brillante le
bonheur parce que avoir une idée qui
tient au corps et qui ne s'en va pas
tout de suite et qui persiste et je
ressens à la fois une sorte d'excitation
d'attente et beaucoup de plaisir parce
que je sais que je vais pouvoir
m'adonner à quelque chose et
m'engouffrer dans une brèche là en fait
ce que j'adore c'est de me dire ok
comment je vais faire pour la réaliser
et trouver tous les cheminements
possibles pour y arriver mais
honnêtement c'est une excitation de
dingue je trouve que c'est vraiment
enfin moi ça me porte quoi complètement
ça me prend totalement la concentration
d'un coup et j'aime beaucoup du coup m'y
mettre à fond tout de suite c'est ouais
ça mélange d'excitation et de
concentration que je ressens quand j'ai
une idée d'abord il peut y avoir de la
rigolade c'est à dire que l'idéal vient
de simplement je me marre sur un truc et
donc d'abord l'idée est là mais je me
rends pas compte que c'est une idée je
peux juste observer le truc un moment me
dire bah tiens ça peut être une idée en
fait c'est pas juste un moment où on se
marre je pense pas forcément à la
faisabilité tout de suite et en fait
parfois j'en ai plein qui sont même pas
faisable en vrai ça me challenge aussi
j'aime bien ça parce qu'il y a beaucoup
d'idées qui sont mortes chez moi ou
c'était un temps ça a l'air chouette et
ouais ça va être vraiment chouette puis
tu en parlait un pote qui te dit
c'est vraiment génial et puis là tu as
ton circuit de récompense qui fait
c'est vrai que c'est génial cette
idée et il faut surtout pas que je la
réalise parce que sinon elle va passer
du statut de waouh génial c'est une
d'idée à une bouse donc je vais
pas la réaliser donc ça c'était une de
mes spécialités ne pas réaliser mes
idées en me disant que que au moins
j'étais pas confronté à l'échec vous
avez vu comment c'est intéressant de
voir qu'on définit pas une bonne idée
sur la faisabilité mais sur nos
sensations et puis sur la nouveauté
notre cerveau il dépense forte à la
dopamine et va être rapidement attirée
par la prochaine idée c'est pour ça que
que des génies comme Léonard de Vinci ou
Victor Hugo n'arrivait pas à se motiver
pour terminer leurs œuvres 20 ans c'est
ce qu'il faudrait à Léonard de Vinci
pour donner le dernier coup de pinceau à
la Joconde Victor Hugo et ses vêtements
à ses employés de maison pour être tout
nu comme ça ils pouvaient pas sortir et
être sûr d'avancer dans son roman et on
lui rendait les vêtements que s'il avait
écrit un chapitre Ludovic parle de
l'aspect réalisable d'une idée et à ce
stade là il se pose pas la question de
savoir si c'est jouable ou pas versineux
se lève un point très intéressant par
les trop tôt d'une idée ça peut offrir
d'ores et déjà la satisfaction de cette
idée et donc enclencher chez nous soit
la peur de l'échec si on réalise l'idée
soit une perte d'envie ou de motivation
parce que le processus de récompense du
cerveau a déjà été enclenché mais il y a
d'autres obstacles qui peuvent venir
interrompre le processus de réalisation
des fois on n'a pas les connaissances
nécessaires ou suffisantes on n'a pas
les moyens matériels financiers
temporels on n'a pas les compétences
mais est-ce que ce sont les véritables
raisons qui font que l'on va au bout de
quelque chose ou pas le projet le plus
marquant c'est évident c'est ma boîte ça
fait que maintenant 12 ans que je bosse
dessus et en fait quand même pour la
petite histoire donc j'ai créé cette
entreprise alors que je ne connaissais
rien au secteur l'idée c'est ça c'est je
me suis fiancée on a été chercher une
mec de fiançailles et j'ai été
honnêtement choqué de voir que
l'expérience chez les grandes maisons
était pas du tout moderne quoi je
trouvais que c'était vieillot j'ai
trouvé que c'était pas chaleureux que
c'était parfois intimidant que c'était
cher enfin bref j'étais honnêtement je
me sentais pas bien et en fait je
connaissais rien à la joaillerie donc je
me disais bon bah ça n'a aucun sens et
je l'ai mis un peu de côté et c'est
toujours cette idée que ça revenait ça
revenait ça revenait ça revenait les
jours passés on en discutait avec mon
mari on se disait mais c'est pas
possible il y a forcément quelque chose
à faire dans ce secteur c'est pas normal
c'est des moments de vie heureux
pourquoi est-ce qu'en fait ça devrait
pas être plus plaisant tout simplement
d'acheter un beau bijou de joaillerie
typiquement j'ai fait une série sur
l'histoire de la télévision je me disais
que ça moi c'était un truc qui me
passionnait j'avais envie de le partager
et en réalité je me suis rendu compte
que les droits ils étaient pas si
accessibles que ça parce que je voulais
utiliser des images d'archives etc j'ai
continué quand même de travailler dessus
en me disant quoi qu'il arrive je
trouverai une solution à ça plus tard et
au final ça a marché parfois ça bloque
complètement et c'est impossible de
faire d'aller au bout de l'idée mais
sinon la plupart du temps je me démerde
quoi je sortait d'une émission de télé
sur France 2 dans laquelle je me
trouvais pas bon la télé c'était pas
pour moi c'était évident donc je voilà
j'avais écarté la télé la radio pareil
j'étais pas assez motivé il y avait pas
assez de public donc je faisais des
blagues à trois personnes dans le studio
c'était pas pour moi et donc l'idée ça a
été de trouver un moyen pour aller sur
internet je vois ces youtubeur qui
commence à faire de la scène et moi
Verino si je suis pas entélélé si je
suis pas radio si je suis pas sur
internet comment je comment je patte le
chaland donc il y avait cet enjeu de cet
enjeu là de créativité et puis l'enjeu
de d'aller affronter un nouveau réseau
une nouvelle manière de faire de la
communication et ce qui s'est passé à ce
moment-là c'est au moment où je prends
toutes ces données là je me dis c'est
évident qu'il faut que j'aille sur
Youtube c'est évident maintenant quelle
est la solution je vais tâtonné quoi il
y a trois choses à retenir la première
c'est que pour être sûr de tenir dans le
temps vous devez commencer par trouver
les raisons profondes qui font que cette
idée elle est importante pour vous je
vous recommande la méthode des pourquoi
ça ça permet de trouver quel les racines
de motivation qui nourrissent cette idée
pourquoi j'ai envie de faire ça parce
que ceci mais pourquoi ceci est
important pour moi parce que cela et
pourquoi cela etc etc la deuxième c'est
que vous ne devez pas attendre d'avoir
la réponse aux questions que vous vous
posez pour démarrer c'est tout bête mais
déjà parce que vous êtes sur un pic de
motivation leur profitez-en surfer
dessus mais surtout parce que vous ne
connaissez pas les bonnes questions les
vraies questions indispensables avant de
venir en cours de route et du coup les
réponses aussi et la troisième chose
c'est que le meilleur moment pour
commencer c'est maintenant si vous
attendez d'avoir le temps d'avoir les
réponses d'avoir une aide extérieure ou
je ne sais pas d'autre pour commencer
sachez que ce moment magique un peu où
tout est aligné pour commencer n'arrive
jamais donc je le répète le meilleur
moment pour commencer c'est maintenant
on va avancer petit à petit et en fait
les problématiques qu'on va rencontrer
on les traitera les unes après les
autres on n'avait pas forcément un plan
global en se disant ben voilà on va on
va faire comme si on va aller par étape
une étape 2 le business plan le truc le
machin pense qu'on s'est dit juste c'est
le côté ça nous passionnait et donc en
fait ce qui nous ce qui nous a vraiment
motivé à y aller même sans avoir aucun
plan de quoi que ce soit c'est le côté
c'est trop cool faut y aller quoi si on
le fait pas de toute façon on va s'en
vouloir de pas le faire quoi entre
l'idée le rêve de créer une marque de
joaillerie et ensuite la réalité qui
était que je suis entrepreneur j'y
connaissais rien je connais rien au
monde de la joie j'ai personne dans mon
milieu qui connaît quoi que ce soit et
donc la réalisation quel était le chemin
et je pense que la chose intelligente
qu'on a faite c'est qu'on s'est dit on
va se fixer une deadline on va se fixer
un un temps assez court pour travailler
sur le projet on peut créer une marque
de joaillerie on sait même pas par où
commencer on n'a pas d'argent on n'y
connaît rien on va se fixer trois mois
pour un 3 mois pour créer un site
internet qui soit capable de vendre des
bijoux si tu as un site internet tu es
capable de vendre des bijoux bah ça veut
dire qu'il faut qu'elle soit des
fournisseurs il faut qu'elle soit des
pierres il faut que tu aies fait design
il faut que tu aies un module de
paiement il faut que sur ton site en
fait a décidé sur quelle plateforme il
faut que tu aies un nom bref le fait
d'avoir un objectif très clair et en
temps assez court pour le réaliser nous
a fait nous forcer en fait à faire plein
de petites actions dans un ordre assez
précis finalement et avoir un fil
directeur quoi tout simplement parce que
le problème souvent quand on est une
idée c'est que c'est flou et du coup on
sait même pas par où commencer c'est
trop gros quoi comme objectif là le fait
que ça soit assez simple c'est à dire
avoir un site internet on est capable de
vendre 5 bijoux c'était déjà quelque
chose de super concret c'est à dire
qu'entre le moment où tu l'as à l'idée
et le moment où tu vas la réaliser il y
a énormément de tu es une locomotive
quoi il y a énormément de wagons à
mettre en place parce que pour que ce
soit un truc qui dure bah il faut que tu
luttes contre toi-même pour réaliser à
quel point tu en as très envie de le
faire et puis que à quel point tu es
capable de le faire à quel point
tu as pas peur de ne pas réussir à le
faire ça c'est aussi un gros point nous
inviter viennent de nous parler
d'éléments très concrets dans le
lancement de leurs projets une fois
l'enthousiasme et l'excitation passée
c'est indispensable que l'excitation
redescende afin de ne pas tomber dans la
distorsion de la réalité dont je vous
parle d'ailleurs dans mon livre entamer
projet alors qu'on est encore sur le
coup du feu sacré ça nous fait prendre
le risque majeur d'aller un peu trop
vite sans être suffisamment préparé à
tout ce qui peut nous attendre que ce
soit les imprévus ou les réels obstacles
qui vont nous obliger à revoir nos plans
il faut comprendre son objectif leur
rendre intelligent c'est à dire
ambitieux mesurable réaliste et utiliser
des outils concrets comme la deadline
dont par le polyn et ses mises une
deadline très courte et très claire
avant d'entamer quoi que ce soit chez
elle c'est un moteur important qui
témoigne d'une réelle lucidité vers
Rhino nous parle de ses démons
intérieurs car ce sont souvent eux nos
pires ennemis quand on entame un chemin
la peur de pas y arriver de ne pas être
capable là encore on a le témoignage
d'une personne lucide qui se prépare à
lutter contre elle-même pour être
certaine d'aller jusqu'au bout
[Musique]
c'est maintenant le moment où il faut
avancer alors que ces instants devraient
être excitant c'est pourtant souvent à
ce stade que beaucoup de personnes
abandonnent moi le premier soit parce
que l'excitation et la motivation sont
passées soit parce que ça nous semble
tout à coup surmontable quand on voit le
travail toute l'énergie que ça va
réclamer on va la retrouver toutes les
excuses plausibles pour ne pas y aller
comme j'ai pas le temps ou je le ferai
plus tard j'ai demandé à mes invités
qu'elles étaient selon eux là où les
qualités nécessaires pour avancer sans
abandonner vous allez être surpris par
les réponses il y a beaucoup
d'entrepreneurs qui ont des idées et qui
après sont coincés parce qu'ils arrivent
pas à faire le premier pas parce qu'il
se pose trop de questions la dernière
chose à faire c'est de se poser toutes
les questions et essayer de tout baliser
va plutôt générer plein d'excuses pour
ne pas avancer et la meilleure approche
c'est l'approche pragmatique de
commencer à exécuter à itérer quand j'ai
des premières idées de concept
immédiatement j'exécute je fais des
prototypes et le plus tôt possible je le
montre parce que clairement il y a une
grande chance que mon idée où on
approche ne soit pas la bonne et j'ai
besoin d'avoir des retours c'est quand
vous avez une idée vous commencez par
vous la faire piquer comme ça vous avez
plus peur d'en parler et on peut passer
à autre chose et en exprimant ces idées
en montrant les premiers prototypes en
la faisant vivre et bien c'est la
meilleure façon de la faire évoluer et
si on reste planqué pendant six mois
dans son bureau son garage son atelier
je ne sais quoi à développer l'idée à
son maximum à faire le prototype le plus
léché possible le plus abouti possible
et même avant de lancer au premier
public d'avoir toutes les
fonctionnalités de se dire non moi je
veux quelque chose de parfait ça c'est
une recette pour le désastre parce que
99% du temps en fait on va être à côté
de la plaque ne pas se poser de
questions c'est une question de survie
se poser trop de questions mais c'est
c'est renoncé en fait c'est qu'en fait
je suis complètement inconsciente et que
du coup quand il y a un problème je me
rends pas forcément compte et ce côté un
peu inconscient un peu obstiné fait
qu'en fait je suis une éternelle
optimiste et que je me dis il y a pas de
solution autre que d'y arriver je sais
que ça va prendre du temps je suis pas
non plus complètement débile mais je
sais que si je m'attelle à une tâche je
vais pouvoir aller au bout des choses et
un exemple qui me vient à l'esprit c'est
quand on a essayé de trouver nos
premiers ateliers avec géniaux j'ai dû
passer mes 250 coups de fil pour réussir
à enfin avoir quelqu'un qui accepte de
me parler enfin vraiment c'était à ce
niveau là et en fait ce qui m'a fait
tenir bah c'est que je savais que ça
allait prendre du temps et que c'était
pas grave je m'autorisais pas le fait
que ça ne marche pas au final je me suis
dit qu'il fallait pas que je commence
trop gros souvent quand on se lance dans
un projet mais en fait on voit hyper
grand et du coup on sait même pas par où
commencer et là je me suis dit il me
suffit d'une fois il me suffit d'un
atelier même petit qui accepte de bosser
avec nous et ça suffira pour le début
moi j'ai plus un côté j'analyse en fait
et quand je suis face à une difficulté
j'aime bien analyser la situation et
voir quelles sont mes différentes
options parce que de toute façon mon
choix il est que quoi qu'il arrive il
faut que je trouve une solution et c'est
d'abord tu te dis effectivement il faut
que j'ai tout balisé mais ça c'est le
côté scolaire quoi moi je suis sûr que
c'est ça ça vient de l'école c'est tant
que tu as pas bien lu tous les non c'est
tu peux pas attaquer les les réponses et
puis du coup tu fais le truc bien comme
il faut et dans l'ordre bah oui mais en
fait non là on met pas dans ce monde-là
en fait là on est dans un monde
d'entrepreneur c'est à dire que si tu
veux que ta vidéo elle soit marrante à
la fin c'est pas la peine de cocher
toutes les cases c'est pas ça l'objectif
c'est pas à la fin bah voilà j'ai fait
ma belle copine non est-ce que c'est
marrant est-ce que c'est pas marrant
comment ça se fait que c'est pas marrant
on adapte on cherche et on trouve en
fait enfin c'est tout con mais
effectivement les chercheurs d'or et
trouver de l'or parce qu'il cherchait de
l'or pas parce qu'ils sont arrivés à un
endroit en faisant c'est sûr que là il y
en a et puis qu'ils ont fait le truc et
puis pouf c'est sorti quoi bah non ils
ont cherché de changer d'endroit
fouiller continuer à creuser et je crois
que je crois que c'est ça une idée quoi
c'est une pépite et je vais tapépite bah
au début tu la vois pas parce qu'elle
est entouré de sable une bonne dose
d'inconscience et de flexibilité voilà
comment on peut résumer les qualités
qu'il faut avoir si vous regardez la
montagne
à franchir si vous avez un plan trop
précis sur lequel partir il y a trop de
chance pour que vous ne puissiez pas
aller jusqu'au bout les imprévus les
obstacles qui attendus ce sont des
passages obligatoires c'est comme dans
un film il y aura toujours des
péripéties si vous refusez cette réalité
vous risquez de vous faire mal acceptez
la marge d'erreur et les imprévus
Eric nous explique qu'il commence tout
de suite par un prototype parce qu'il
sait qu'il est pas abouti et que ça a
besoin d'être amélioré c'est un point
fondamental n'essayez pas d'être parfait
ni de rendre une copie sans rature soyez
pragmatique Pauline nous explique très
bien qu'elle s'est donné une étape
concrète au moment de se lancer créer un
site internet ça va c'est envisageable
partir sans tout baliser ça signifie pas
y aller sans organiser les premières
étapes qui révèlent elles de la logique
puis via notre phénomène que vous
connaissez que je connais c'est la perte
de motivation c'est souvent là que nous
sommes très tentés d'arrêter parce qu'on
est plus animés c'est la motivation
c'est le carburant de du cerveau la
persévérance c'est un peu l'état du
véhicule l'état du cerveau je crois
qu'il faut pas confondre la motivation
la persévérance et puis l'obstination en
réalité je pense que personne n'est tout
le temps et quand on est persévérant ça
veut pas dire qu'on a le feu sacré en
permanence et qu'on est vraiment en
train de se dire allez il faut que j'y
aille il faut que j'y aille tout le
temps et j'adore le projet non il y a
des moments on a des coups de mou moi je
me rappelle avec mon podcast ça fait
maintenant quand même 5 ans qu'il existe
j'ai eu des périodes où sortir un
épisode toutes les semaines que Dieu
fait mais c'est monstrueux si jamais je
fixe pas une deadline qui est que toutes
les semaines le lundi j'ai un épisode
qui sort mais franchement je sais très
bien qu'au bout de deux semaines
j'aurais arrêté et donc c'était
absolument nécessaire pour moi de me
connaître de savoir que je suis pas si
discipline que ça et donc il fallait que
je m'impose cette discipline justement
et que je le dise aussi publiquement et
donc d'ailleurs j'ai fait cet exercice
j'ai dit très souvent à mon audience moi
mon épisode de podcast c'est tous les
lundis matins comme ça ça me forçait à
le faire je suis nature persévérante
mais sur des trucs qui me passionne
c'est à dire il faut vraiment qu'il y
ait pour moi un côté
où je m'éclate dans ce que je fais
vraiment pour que je puisse persévérer
par contre dans ces cas là je lâche rien
vraiment je peu importe les difficultés
peu porte les choses je vais jusqu'au
bout de ce que j'ai envie de faire mais
pour ça il faut que j'ai toujours
l'espèce de flamme si vraiment ça me
plaît pas j'ai aucune motivation à le
faire je
n'arriverai à trouver aucune solution
c'est comme un accouchement en fait
c'est arrivé avec ton avec ton bébé et
puis et puis bah 20 ans plus tard il a
20 ans ton gamin et donc il y a toute
une évolution il y a il y a Liné que ce
que tu as au début je dirais c'est ça
dans un spectacle tu arrives avec l'inné
et puis ensuite il y a Laki c'est de le
confronter au spectateur tous les soirs
de l'améliorer de le et de le renforcer
de te mettre face à ce que tu voulais
dire aussi parfois il y a des trucs où
ton idée elle a l'air bonne puis tu la
mets sur scène et puis les gens trouvent
ça plutôt chouette et puis trois
semaines plus tard tu te rends compte
que ton idée en fait elle est raciste
c'est pas du tout c'est pas une bonne
idée je parlerai racisme mais j'aurais
pu parler de de misogynie ou de
n'importe quoi d'autre mais je veux dire
il est parfois
nécessaire de entre le moment où tu as
ton idée que tu la mets en place et que
tu es content de la mettre en place et
puis le moment où tu la regardes avec un
peu le cerveau à froid bah il y a encore
tout une évolution où tu te rends compte
que tu l'as dit plus la même et que ça
va plus la même chose il faut avoir
vraiment la foi quoi quand je cherche à
essayer de comprendre quel artiste je
suis moi je crois que je suis un roseau
quoi c'est un jeu plie mais je rompre à
voir la foi vers une explique très bien
dans son passage car il sait que le
chemin va être long il peut être long se
met dans le bûche de déception et qu'il
faut être prêt à revoir notre copine
notre stratégie et s'adapter aux
imprévus une embûches c'est pas le signe
que l'idée est mauvaise ou que le projet
est pas viable qu'il faut le jeter elle
fait partie du processus on peut pas y
déroger c'est là que la persévérance
doit prendre le pas sur la motivation
une bonne idée c'est facile à voir mais
l'énergie nécessaire pour la réaliser
c'est autre chose la motivation c'est le
premier déclencheur qui va nous faire
passer du stade de l'idée au premier pas
pour la réaliser mais ça a duré de vie
et de très courte durée finalement cette
persévérance nous inviter vont la
chercher dans les caractéristiques de
leur personnalité qu'ils connaissent
bien versino nous expliquer plutôt qu'il
attend de terminer une idée pour savoir
si elle était bonne ou pas Pauline elle
sait qu'elle est indisciplinée malgré
toute la motivation du monde elle sait
que c'est un danger pour son projet et
donc elle se met une pression extérieure
publiquement ces objectifs vous devez
vous adapter en fonction de votre
personnalité de votre caractère pour
mettre en place un panel d'outils qui
vont vous servir à mettre en place une
sorte de grille et de parcours à suivre
pour être certain d'atteindre vos
objectifs allez au bout d'une idée ça
passe indéniablement par une certaine
connaissance de soi-même il y a plein de
questions à vous poser sur les qualités
que vous possédez un train segment sur
les faiblesses dont vous devez vous
méfier moi j'ai répondu aussi à tout ça
j'ai pris une feuille j'ai écrit et je
vous invite à faire la même chose avant
de commencer quoi que ce soit et c'est
une fois que j'ai répondu à toutes ces
questions que j'ai pu me lancer à faire
plusieurs projets si vous avez
d'ailleurs l'impression depuis 6 ans ou
7 ans que je lance plein de projets bah
c'est pas hasard mes invités eux
viennent de parler des choses qui te
sont faites qu'ils ont réalisées ils ont
admis leurs erreurs leur inconscience
leur carence j'ai donc demandé quels
conseils il se donnerait à eux-mêmes du
moins la version d'eux-mêmes du passé
celle qu'ils étaient au moment où ils
ont commencé en fait je lui parlerai pas
j'y toucherai pas avec le recul je
m'aperçois que la moindre modification
le la moindre énergie qui va aller dans
un autre endroit viendrait complètement
oubliée éradiquer le chemin et je sais
pas du tout je pourrais me retrouver
moins de réflexion plus d'action alors
ça paraît complètement contre intuitif
mais en réalité moi je suis convaincu
qu'il faut tester 150 trucs pour trouver
la bonne idée parce qu'en fait au final
on sait jamais ce qui va marcher j'ai
mis au marché peut-être que ça aurait pu
être autre chose et au final je trouve
que tester tester 150 nouvelles choses à
petit échelle avec beaucoup de volume en
fait ça te permet à un moment donné
toujours quand même de tirer les fruits
quoi de ce que tu as semé en fait me
donner des conseils aujourd'hui sur le
mois du passé ça changerait aussi le
mois du passé et je trouve ça dommage
parce que je pense que c'est dans
l'échec qu'on apprend dans la difficulté
qu'on apprend et si après j'ai trop de
conseils et je peux pas apprendre
moi-même sur le terrain ben je trouve ça
je trouve que ça enlève pas mal de chose
la réponse est globale à toutes les
personnes à qui j'ai pu parler de ce
sujet et de cette thématique
l'apprentissage la maîtrise d'une chose
passe indéniablement par le
franchissement des obstacles mais
comment on peut appréhender les défis à
relever dans nos aventures obligatoires
il va y avoir des problèmes c'est un peu
comme quand je fais des reportages à
l'étranger je pars souvent dans des
zones un peu éloignées etc et du coup à
chaque fois que je pars je me dis
quelle va être le problème que je vais
rencontrer cette fois-ci parce que je
sais quoi qu'il arrive qu'il va y avoir
un truc qui va y avoir une couille
quelque part il va y avoir quelque chose
qui marche pas même si le plan est le
plus complet possible il y a que la peur
qui t'empêche d'avancer en fait c'est
c'est qu'est-ce qui qui c'est le moment
où tu te rends compte à quel point tu es
médiocre et que tu dis tiens je peux pas
montrer ça aux gens quoi on a de
véritables utilité c'est d'oser aller
affronter les choses qui nous qui nous
terrifient et donc s'habituer à aller en
territoire hostile quoi effectivement la
le territoire de la peur c'est le pire
je me dis bah fait et après on voit tu
décales la peur mais tu décales la peur
au moment où le résultat est là pas au
moment où tu imagines le résultat et tu
le fantasme et tu fantasmes jamais les
choses correctement tu les fantasmes
toujours nuls tout ça pour dire que faut
pas s'empêcher c'est une fois que le
Produit est terminé qu'on le juge alors
ok les obstacles ils sont indispensables
faites-vous à cette idée et
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
c'est pas une mauvaise chose chaque
obstacle est l'occasion de vous rendre
plus créatif pour trouver des solutions
de vous apprendre des leçons précieuses
pour mener à bien tous les autres
projets qui viendront dans le futur il
faut accepter que ce sont soit des
erreurs soit des imprévus qu'on apprend
vraiment des choses personnellement j'ai
appris qu'à partir d'un obstacle je
pouvais trouver différents chemins en
fait propres à mes connaissances pour
m'en sortir et attention les anecdotes
elles peuvent donner l'illusion que ça
s'applique qu'aux projets professionnels
mais ce sont les mêmes mécanismes qui
s'appliquent pour les envies
personnelles courir un marathon à
prendre une langue écrire un roman
monter une boîte je sais pas et même
même créer une soirée d'anniversaire
surprise je vous parlais tout à l'heure
rapidement de maître de l'ambition dans
son idée pour être certain qu'elle soit
stimulante et pour pas la laisser tomber
en cours de route alors attention une
ambition réaliste un légère si je garde
l'exemple de la soirée d'anniversaire
surprise une ambition ça serait
d'organiser une journée d'anniversaire
surprise une ambition non réaliste ce
serait de créer une semaine
d'anniversaire surprise d'ailleurs une
fois il l'idée réalisé j'ai demandé à
mes invités ce qu'ils ont vécu et ce
qu'ils ont appris on est en voyage
continu il y a pas de il y a pas de
destination en fait il est foi ou
finalement je me suis peut-être fait la
réflexion que ça y est c'est fait en
fait immédiatement mais je me suis
désintéressé de de l'idée du projet
pendant trois ans presque quatre ans
j'ai travaillé surprising le comparateur
de prix donc je trouvais des associés
j'ai bossé j'ai recruté du monde j'ai
levé des fonds enfin je me suis battu
pour cette application saouler ma femme
avec puis un jour je me suis rendu
compte que
j'arriverai pas à le transformer en
grande boîte en grande entreprise parce
que l'internationalisation c'est
compliqué la scalabilité c'est compliqué
enfin bref à un moment je me suis dit
faut que je passe à autre chose j'ai
trouvé un acheteur je l'ai vendu
et du jour au lendemain enfin le soir
même après que c'était acté vendu je me
suis désintéressé mais complètement du
projet pour moi c'était mort et ma femme
était choquée elle comprenait pas que
j'ai pu passer en fait d'un d'une telle
obsession à un tel même pas un rejet
c'est simplement une c'était quelque
chose qui avait plus d'importance pour
moi et c'est là où j'ai compris que
c'est le plaisir de la réalisation d'une
idée il est super
à l'idée au projet finit en lui-même et
je pense que c'est ça s'arrête jamais
une fois qu'on a accompli quelque chose
il faut tout de suite accomplir autre
chose je repense à Eric Antoine en 2008
qui m'avait dit en fait toi ce qu'il
faut avec ta gueule d'ange c'est de
l'humour noir et c'est un super conseil
mais que j'ai pas du tout écouté sur le
moment parce que parce que c'était un
conseil que je n'étais pas du tout prêt
à entendre puis c'est un conseil que
j'avais pas envie d'entendre en fait je
crois que je crois que j'ai envie de
faire mon chemin en fait je crois que ce
qui intéresse plus le Vérino du passé
c'est pas tant de lui donner les
solutions c'est de
c'est le Vérino je me souviens de toutes
les étapes de ma création générale de
artistique moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
le chemin quoi c'est même pas le c'est
même pas le résultat quoi j'avoue que
j'aime bien moi la pression des pères
j'aime bien l'idée de me forcer parce
que je dois être sensible à regarder des
autres mais de me forcer publiquement à
faire les choses parce que je sais que
j'aurais pu le choix quand j'ai dit que
je m'engage verbalement publiquement sur
quelque chose d'une certaine manière
j'ai plus le choix et donc bah il faut
avoir une certaine force d'esprit aussi
de doser faire ça mais quand on le fait
je trouve qu'on est toujours remercier
parce que ça nous force à avancer quoi
tout simplement que ça m'a appris
surtout c'est d'être polyvalent en vrai
et de connaître vraiment un le minimum
sur plein de sujets différents moi ce
que j'aime bien là-dessus c'est essayer
d'avoir une ouverture d'esprit sur plein
de choses essayer de comprendre plein de
choses pour tout projet il faut pour
qu'il réussisse dans sa globalité être
un petit peu au courant d'un peu tout
voilà et alors on demande pas d'être le
pro du montage de la caméra pas du tout
mais au moins de comprendre comment ça
fonctionne parce que ça
ça permet d'imbriquer toutes les
différentes pièces du puzzle parce que
pour moi un projet c'est un énorme
puzzle et au final ben si on connaît un
minimum de trucs sur chaque on peut
nous-mêmes arriver à avoir une idée
globale arriver à assembler le puzzle et
finalement pouvoir aussi changer les
choses et voir comment les choses
s'organisent mieux parce que parce que
les gens ils ont beau être hyper fort
dans un truc ils ont peut-être pas des
infos sur une autre partie et en ayant
un minimum de connaissances on arrive
finalement à avoir un côté macro et
pouvoir mieux organiser les trucs
[Musique]
dans cette partie nous allons parler du
moment où nous avons atteint notre
objectif une fois que le but a été
touché c'est derrière nous alors
qu'est-ce qu'on ressent est-ce que la
réalité à la hauteur du fantasme qu'on
s'était fait qu'est-ce qui se passe
ensuite ce qui est un peu dur c'est
quand j'atteins un objectif moi je vais
déjà étape d'après et la vérité c'est
que j'ai un petit problème mais je crois
que je peux la seule c'est que j'ai un
peu de mal à m'arrêter quoi et quand
j'ai une nouvelle idée je suis un peu
éthique à cette idée j'arrive à
l'objectif et puis il est là et je suis
déjà en train de voir l'étape d'après
donc j'essaye de me forcer maintenant à
célébrer les choses et donc typiquement
ce que j'aime bien faire c'est quand
j'ai un objectif et que je l'atteins le
célébrer réellement et avoir fixé en
amont qui doit être la récompense
j'invite un certain nombre de personnes
à faire un super dîner et du coup on va
bien on va bien passer un bon moment et
on va se rappeler en fait qu'on a
atteint l'objectif parce que le problème
c'est que souvent quand on est trop dans
la roue qui tourne quoi ben on oublie
quoi tout simplement qu'on est quand
même arrivé au bout de notre objectif
j'ai envie de passer à la suivante je
suis pas trop un gars qui regarde en
arrière ou qui tu vois même pour les
vidéos qui regardent ces vidéos
longtemps non une fois que la vidéo elle
est sortie
je n'y pense plus et je passe à la suite
et c'est pareil sur les projets j'ai par
contre j'ai toujours besoin de projets
déjà d'avoir des projets ça m'apporte
que je me sens en vie ça c'est pas
pourquoi mais j'ai l'impression de
mourir si j'ai pas de projet j'ai
l'impression qu'on va me ranger dans un
petit placard là et puis ciao bonsoir
même d'ailleurs je le vois sur mes c'est
fou mais même dans mon parcours YouTube
j'ai eu plusieurs chaînes YouTube et en
fait je me dis bah tiens quand celle-là
ça me saoulera ces projets là mais je
recrée une autre chaîne Youtube et
parfois j'ai envie parce que j'aime bien
les challenges j'aimais tout ça mais à
partir du moment où il y a un visuel à
ce moment où notre boîte a eu un logo à
partir du moment où linglorious j'ai
trouvé le nom Inglorious titre de mon
dernier spectacle c'est focus pareil
j'étais hyper content de le trouver bah
c'est à partir du moment où il y a
l'affiche et qui a quelque chose qui
peut être matériellement
que matérialissable quoi je crois que
c'est ça qui me et c'est pareil pour les
vidéos quoi un projet existe en réalité
il commence à exister parce que c'est un
chemin long l'existence du projet fait
que on se dit que c'est le début de
l'aventure finalement on se dit ça y est
ça avance on passe des étapes et quelque
part ça s'arrête jamais puisque quand on
crée une entreprise dans les statuts on
les crée pour 99 ans et c'est plus long
que
notre vie une entreprise s'est fait pour
nous survivre et
donc la notion d'achèvement je pense
n'existe pas ou en tout cas elle
n'existe que par rapport à son fondateur
ou fondateur lorsqu'il va sortir de
l'entreprise ou vendre les parts de
l'entreprise ou lorsque l'entreprise va
péricliter mais sinon il y a il y a pas
de notion de chef-d'oeuvre d'achèvement
en fait une entreprise comme je vous le
disais au début de cette vidéo avoir une
idée un projet c'est une drogue dure et
bien souvent on est en recherche de
cette dopamine permanente on veut
retrouver ses sensations mais regardez
Pauline elle se force à célébrer ses
victoires et à bien raison parce que
c'est souvent un truc qu'on oublie de
faire plus on atteint l'accomplissement
de notre idée plus on oublie que c'était
un but en soi à atteindre et que ce but
il mérite d'être vécu récompensé et
célébré dans le cas de Vérino il nous
parle de son plateau d'humoriste
évidemment c'est pas une fois qu'il est
créé que l'aventure va se terminer il y
a tout imperfectionner surtout il y a
beaucoup d'énergie à fournir pour que
cela perdure dans le temps ce n'est pas
une fois que le but est atteint que
l'aventure s'arrête comme dit Eric la
fin ce n'est que le début d'une autre
aventure avant de passer à la suite je
voudrais prendre une seconde pour
remercier les intervenants de cette
vidéo pour avoir accepté de répondre à
mes questions le plus sincèrement et le
plus honnêtement possible les chaînes
Youtube de Vérino et de Ludovic B sont
en lien dans la description et je vous
encourage vivement à les découvrir leur
travail vous trouverez aussi le compte
de Pauline Lemieux sur lequel vous
trouverez les informations pour écouter
son magnifique podcast le gratin mais
aussi pour découvrir sa marque gemio
pour Eric l'archevêque je vous mets
également son lien vers son compte
Instagram où il donne des précieux
conseils pour tous ceux qui veulent être
entrepreneurs mais vous pouvez aussi le
retrouver dans l'émission sur M6 qui
veut être mon associé merci à eux je
vous en parlais au tout début de la
vidéo donc aujourd'hui le 4 mai il y a
mon nouveau livre mon septième qui vient
de sortir dans toutes les librairies y
compris la librairie à côté de chez vous
c'est bien de se tenir les libraires
c'est aussi disponible d'ailleurs sur
tous les sites en ligne les grands
classiques Fnac Amazon cultura etc il
sort en format papier d'ailleurs mais il
sort aussi en format audio j'ai lu
moi-même mon propre livre donc il est
sur audible et ce genre de plateforme je
vous mets les liens vers tout ça dans la
description de toute manière si vous
avez lu votre temps est infini vous
allez vous y retrouver c'est une espèce
de pièce de puzzle qui qui s'imbriquent
avec votre temps est infini le bonheur
est caché dans un coin de votre cerveau
et celui-ci si vous n'avez pas lu les
autres c'est pas grave il se mis
indépendamment en gros toute ma vie j'ai
eu plein d'idées à la seconde ça c'est
sûr par contre je suis un énorme
procrastinateur abstinant c'est à dire
que je remets des choses au lendemain
mais en fait j'essaye de pas le faire et
et j'ai essayé de comprendre en fait
c'était quoi les difficultés pour aller
au bout de d'une idée quelle qu'elle
soit tu vois pour la transformer en
quelque chose de matériel et c'est 20
ans que j'ai essayé de commencer là à
l'intérieur de ça rien qui crie ce livre
ben je l'écris en m'appliquant les
conseils que je donne dans le livre donc
c'est pas des conseils du style je suis
un professeur et fais ce que je dis et
tu m'as tout comprendre c'est c'est
vraiment mon expérience d'ailleurs je
prends des grandes anecdotes où
j'extrais la substance pour vous
expliquer pourquoi j'ai mis ça en place
parce que il fallait que toutes les
techniques dont je vous parle elles
soient concrètes c'est à dire que elles
aient un sens dans le cerveau et que ça
sorte pas de mon chapeau et que vous
puissiez comprendre pourquoi je les
avais mis en place moi et comment elle
fonctionne mais ça marche aussi bien du
point de vue professionnel ou personnel
je pense c'est presque un peu présentiel
mais que ça peut s'adapter à n'importe
quelle chose je vais peut-être vous
faire voir un petit peu l'intérieur en
gros ça se découpe en trois grandes
parties sur le fait qu'au commencement
il y a une idée sur comment transformer
une idée en un objectif qui est
réalisable ça paraît bête dit comme ça
mais en fait c'est toute cette partie là
qui je crois est la plus utile pour être
sûr de pas abandonner par la suite
comment on fait ensuite pour emmener son
projet son idée jusqu'au bout jusqu'à la
réalisation et l'atelier alors l'atelier
c'est à peu près tous les outils que
j'ai développé que je mets en place pour
moi du style concerné versus impliqué
l'art de la fiabilité comme on règle un
focus comment on se crée un conseiller
personnel dans sa tête etc j'ai mis tout
ça là dedans et c'est vous qui aurait
piocher dans l'atelier les outils qui
vont vous servir au fur et à mesure je
suis très heureux de faire ça c'est la
7e année que je vous dis que je sors un
livre alors que en 2016 quand j'étais en
train d'écrire mon premier qui était
sorti en 2017 c'était un peu fou vous
étiez 27000 abonnés sur cette chaîne
d'ailleurs quand j'ai commencé la
rédaction du premier livre ben voilà
apparemment c'est devenu une partie de
ma vie d'écrire des livres tant que j'ai
des choses à dire en tout cas celui-ci
bah c'est l'un des plus essentiels parce
que il répond à la question qu'on m'a le
plus posé c'est cette dernière année de
et comment tu fais pour faire tous ces
projets en même temps ben la réponse
elle est là que ce soit d'un point de
vue perso ou professionnel j'espère
qu'il vous sera utile j'ai hâte de vous
croiser pour que vous puissiez me
raconter quelque chose vous avez mis en
place en utilisant des astuces du livre
et voilà prenez soin de vous tout est
dans la description à très bientôt Ciao
[Musique]